it's easy to be a solitary hero in a
video game or a well-armed adult in a
squad of other well-armed adults my
mentality in games like Mass Effect or
fallout is always sacrifice yourself
because for the purposes of story
progression you can't die at least not
until the end and then you get to be a
hero in the same vein of gamifying
morality most games make it pretty clear
how to be good and how to be evil the
only tricky bit is having to part with a
hundred coins to pay someone's rent or
what-have-you to get a positive morality
bump that said I've played a few games
lately that have made morality and
decision making far more complicated and
that's because of one very clever
addition kids now I don't have any kids
never been around any for any length of
time and I'd count myself among those
not easily swayed by a cherub faced tiny
human but it sure is harder to be a
ruthless gun-toting war hero with a
child next to you watching your every
move
getting themselves in trouble and most
importantly if they're well-written
actually making you want to change the
way you act around them yep I'm ready to
crash - lets go what no you're gonna
miss our makeover skill I'll fall asleep
and then you'll turn my ear on Oh get
out of here see in the morning you
didn't have to come with me
you know I know if you weren't already
aware this is the case in life is
strange - where the series has switched
characters for the sequel and now we're
following 17-year old Shawn and his 9
year old brother Daniel who is pretty
much a human guilt mechanic the main
thrust of the narrative is that you're
on the road and as you'd remember from
such adventures as almost every RPG
stealing is pretty much always fair game
so long as you don't get caught not so
in the case of life is strange - where
Daniel watches and learns from your
actions I spent three episodes letting
Daniel throw around the odd f-bomb and
now he sounds like a sailor on leave and
this is the monster I've created ready
to rumble hey if you still in front of
him he'll steal of his own accord and
you'll only find out when you settle at
the next location and he's mysteriously
collected
new toy to say this feels terrible would
be an understatement and since the
characters of life is strange two are
both really well-written there's a whole
new weight to the way you carry yourself
in the game world how you treat other
characters and the typical gamey things
you have to give up in order to not feel
like the world's worst role model one of
the earliest games that made a lot of
gamers feel protective of a young
companion is Telltale's The Walking Dead
the protagonist Lee discovers a young
girl Clementine hiding out in her
treehouse longing for her parents to
return home Lee takes Clementine honors
award as neither he nor the player wants
to leave her to brave the zombie hordes
alone given the game revolves around
decision making and the consequences of
your actions there's a lot to consider
in how you act around Clementine and how
you impact who she becomes then there
are games like until dawn where although
your characters are way more likely to
die they don't elicit the same level of
panic over the responsible or moral
thing to do
since every character is similarly
self-sufficient it's easy to make
choices as Ethan in heavy rain since his
motivation is to save his son Shawn so
you simply throw yourself into the
firing line or more accurately the
chopping off your own finger line you to
ensure you gather enough clues to save
him
the difficulty in these moments is
getting the QuickTime events right but
choosing to push forward through
obstacles to ensure Shawn's safe return
is a no brainer things get messy when
taking care of kids isn't the end game
but rather when they're tied up in the
same mess as you this is the crux of a
plague tale innocence the new play
graphic adventure from asobo studio and
focus home it follows a Masjid Arun and
her little brother Hugo making their way
through the rat filled streets of France
during the early years of the Black
Death it's a difficult time filled with
rough decisions to make while trying not
to get eaten alive or skewered by the
soldiers hunting you
most of the horrifying series of events
are unavoidably laid out for you and
poor little Hugo who's voice actor gives
a positively heartbreaking performance
if you want to don't burn yourself thank
you
for mummy and daddy watch over them
embodying ameesha as she kills for the
first time and gasps sickened at her own
actions is affecting in and of itself
but when hugo sees you take out a
soldier that's when you feel far worse
this has really driven home further into
the game I found myself trying every
which way to avoid killing when Hugo was
trailing along behind me holding my hand
but in the sections a meteor goes off on
her own I was far more comfortable going
all shadow with the Tomb Raider on
whoever got in my way in the Last of Us
and God of War our heroes appeared with
Ellie and at Reyes respectively and
while the two of them are more useful in
combat and can even be trained to
improve they're still very young and you
feel a responsibility and a fondness for
them though a plague tales Hugo is five
and absolutely precious and must be
protected that sentiment is the same
regardless of how capable your young
companion is and that's because of the
excellent writing and characterization
that's a hallmark of each of these games
it heavily impacts your ability to
empathize with Joel Kratos and ameesha
and subsequently their journeys and
character arcs what have you found it's
st. John's wort oh it will protect you
when you go to the tongue must be
powerful stuff yes it's a very good
flower it looks good on you
thank you a plague tale is also a
stealth game and having a tiny Ward in
tow adds an incredible emotional layer
to stealth sequences the threat level
and intensity in games like Dishonored
or even amnesia is certainly palpable
but having the responsibility of keeping
a child safe even though it's just the
illusion of an extra level of difficulty
makes these situations far more tense
Hugo and Clementine from The Walking
Dead aren't actually in any more danger
than your protagonists and don't present
any new difficulties to your gameplay
experience but they seem like they do so
the inclusion is quite clever there's
something about the humanity and yeah I
have to say it
a sense of Hugo in a plague tale
innocence just as there is with
Clementine and Daniel it cuts through
your preconceived understanding of how
you can get away with behaving as a
video game protagonist as the concept of
consequences is reintroduced returning
to the idea of being the solitary hero
in these games you don't own and face
those consequences singularly you have
to share them with someone dependent who
relies on you of course it's still a
game and you can still do whatever you
want but the Walking Dead and a plague
tale don't have the same revel in the
gore and violence feeling we're all so
used to with the majority of shooters
and action games to reintroduce impact
and emotional weight to violence is a
difficult thing in video games a point
that couldn't have been made better by
the fact that a plague tale innocence
arrived less than a month after Mortal
Kombat 11 introducing kids pulls it just
about everyone's biological heartstrings
and exploiting that little bit of human
psychology creates a refreshing new lens
to experience classic videogame tropes
as a Mesa is older companion Tulsa in a
plague tale it's easy to spill blood but
to love and protect turns out that adds
a whole new dimension I'm sorry
listen we are going to find a way to
kill you